hello good afternoon good morning good
evening wherever the hell you are in the
world and welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel with these
two idiots over here Aaron one American
Harris another bloody American
yeah
um Aaron's is Frozen
that's the perfect Frozen spot too that
was
that was glorious I love it when that
happens
um
say hello and then I'll run the credits
howdy howdy howdy
hello
[Music]
so we have a couple of things we're
going to be discussing today so we I've
got a little bit of a game we're going
to be paying a bit of fantasy streaming
service CEO a little later where we're
going to pick our shows from our own
streaming services that we now own
apparently I now own Amazon Prime by the
way thank you
um
we're going we have some Stargate news
for you which I'm going to drop on you
in a little minute or two but first of
all
all three of us for once have actually
watched a movie which has never happens
normally we have to explain this to a
certain somebody who will just say shut
up Matt that we have to explain it to
him what this movie is about then we've
actually all three of us have seen it
and guys before I get into it is it fair
to say
that Marvel have actually made a good
movie
and that we were all shocked yes yes
minorly shocked but also grateful
grateful is a good word I like that
um what were you saying yesterday Aaron
a bunch you said it was uh like you just
felt relief right
yeah that's fun yeah it was it was
walking in there and
and
obviously
before we talk about how much we love
this was there anything in it you
weren't massively excited about before
we let's get the negative out of the way
before we talk about the positives
anything
uh Paris
well uh
I was kind of waiting on Aaron because
we did kind of talk about this a little
yesterday where I I don't really have
that I didn't really find too many
thoughts with the movie but if I had to
uh if I had to which they can explain it
away for this one Adam Warlock just
being uh that dumbed down was a little
much sometimes but that was like
literally it and it really wasn't all
that much because you know he is a baby
out of the Cocoon they say okay we take
him out of the Cocoon early we should
have let him just date longer
but
it still would have been cool to have
him actually you know be a fully
realized being and and do some cool
things with that even though he did some
really cool things without being a fully
realized team
[Music]
um
yeah he was a bit of a dumbass I was
hoping he would be because obviously
that actors I don't know his name but oh
they go he's he really bulked up for
that and he really like filled the part
and but he still kind of played the
character he normally plays yeah I was a
little bit disappointed by that I
thought they were actually going to make
him a fully rounded proper new superhero
and they've kind of
made him an idiot book I I think he's
got potential I do like the actor but he
did kind of get relegated to the same
role that he typically plays instead of
turning into like that fully realized
superhero or on the verge of becoming
one
yeah this little baby how about you
around anything that sort of made to go
hmm or was it all good
uh for the most part it was good
um Adam dirt block was a little Annoying
um
some of uh
some of this container a little
um that whole base being logically based
in the their security teams big old
poofy fleshy suits with a little
but for the most part it was actually
for a gun movie it was like super heavy
like emotionally impactful and heavy and
that that's I think what I got most
actually that's the biggest thing both
my wife and I got out of that was it was
he was in your face with the uh
with the intensity in this one which
considering these last couple movies
were frankly shocking
yeah
did uh
because I know you you and your wife
weren't big fans on like animal animal
cruelty even like being depicted or yada
yada did that sway your liking this of
the film at all or or was it did it
increase like okay now I feel for these
characters more or was it like all right
that's enough like you can you can shoot
the other direction you know
um kind of a little bit of the last two
I mean it was I know it was necessary to
the story because the High
evolutionaries character of just being
the way he is
um and it was really cool to get Rockets
backstory I thought it didn't seemed you
know obviously he's been unwilling to
talk about it himself to this point so
um but yeah it was it wasn't off-putting
it was just very
I mean I was glad they cut away before
it got really really really Intense or
where they showed that he was probably
gonna be going with it so like they he
literally cut those scenes right at the
line where he needed to like he took it
right to that point and then I was like
all right we're good so yeah hi Carrie
but uh um
I was actually fairly impressed like I
said I give that movie a solid 8. yeah
over here in the UK the only thing I
added a little bit of an issue is was
they're really pushing the boundaries or
12 A's
I mean they're really pushing the
boundaries there was a lot of swearing
in this film for a kid I mean I I take
my 40 year old kids no bother watch this
film no bother at all I take my I had
took him last year no bother but legally
I could take my seven or eight year old
daughter to watch it and I would be
honestly going
oh yeah this is a bit much you know I
mean it's like
I do think they're really pushing what a
12a is and and I think they're going too
far some of the swearing was a bit much
but some of the
violence this film I think they could
have gone just a little bit further and
just made it 15 it would have been a
much better film
um see you're throwing me off with all
these different UK ratings of things all
I know is
I will tell you I will tell you it here
here in the colonies
um
even under what we call PG-13 which I
assume is whatever you said you're 12.
12a
so rpg-13 is your 12. I'm I assume and
uh here you're allowed one F-bomb and it
can still be PG-13 yeah but it's kind of
similar over here but there's r or a for
you
so we have
um Universal anybody can watch anything
Parental Guidance so again you can take
a kid but it's
um Parental Guidance so you should be
warned there might be some rudeness
12a which is I think like you said your
PG-13 which is 12 12 year olds and Under
12 is allowed to watch it with a parent
um and then we've got 15 and 18 and 18
as I imagine you are is it R rated or
something yeah it just means we skip we
go right from 13 to R and then that's R
is you need to be accompanied by a
parent or Guardian what yeah we got TV
14 for TV I guess technically if we put
it all together it'd be like tvy tv y7 g
p g PG-13 TV 14 R and then NC 17 if
you're going that far yeah tvla is
basically like it's basically like movie
R because you know a lot of those yeah
that yeah usually I would say that but
it's it's R it's the same difference we
don't really have a TV version we
basically have a watershed where we can
put anything on before the walk shed
after nine o'clock you know a bit more
but then you're only allowed certain
things after 11 p.m so
um the really bad stuff but it's
normally that's relegated like
pornography stuff that's getting into
the more sexualized content is not
allowed until after 11.
um unless it's a locked channel so like
we've got like 24-hour streaming porn
basically and the movie channel anything
you have to put a pin in you can watch
anytime yeah but yeah
um what were the what were the bits and
what did you think was really powerful
because I mean obviously we've said this
is probably the best Marvel movie since
end game
is that fair yeah I think so I think
it's the best since Infinity War I like
it more than in game
yeah okay I'll give you that uh I would
say it since Multiverse I still like I
still like I would still put multi
up there with easily
but it's definitely the best Multiverse
for me
yeah I hated Multiverse Madness
oh you did I forgot about that
awful the storyline
wandered you know the best thing I like
about going to the galaxies this whole
thing with rocket and they've made him
like he's the genius and the bad guy
really really wants rocket we see that
sometimes in the third party movies and
he's sort of got Wonder because well
that character's a genius or since
when's that character been this
important but then in this you go oh all
the way through you're like yeah 100
it's like
makes sense
um sorry Mark
you're 21st street drag me up not
personally but probably I don't I'm too
honest
I said that but now I'm thinking about
it I don't really know like I've got the
internet who would need it
but God love him and then yeah I will
guide him
yeah
if I end him
um yeah it's called upon there you go I
don't know that one see I'm an old man I
don't think
um internet
so the nice thing about the guy who's
the Galaxy 3 before we move on to the
Stargate news
um
it the special effects were good
they were great nothing in it was bad
yes yeah
they really strange seem to have figured
out the problems I'm hoping they're
going to slow down a little bit but but
yeah oh um sepi just said the guy
playing the main villain
oh
what an actor chick where do you or some
[__] like that he killed it
uh Chuck Woody something uh I can never
say the last name
yeah it's incredible
yeah absolutely incredible actor I'm
absolutely amazed it I've absolutely
smashed it
so we're getting a few people and then
going saying
God he's so demanding but we're here
so I'm gonna run the Stargate audio
um
okay
it's frozen it freezes on the best
frames though the it does it does um I
don't know if if Aaron wants to have a
let me take myself off Wi-Fi while we're
gone I'll be back
three minutes this video is and this is
going to be a news then we'll discuss it
when we come back here we go
foreign
[Music]
welcome to Stargate news and rumors your
weekly look at everything Stargate as we
look forward to the new series and movie
getting announced
so what is news this week well obviously
the right to strike happened
the writers have put down their pens and
no new scripts will be produced until
they can resolve this situation so does
that mean Stargate is on pause with so
many other projects well I'm told no I'm
told that actually this was always part
of the plan and why they were waiting
until mid-june to even announce that
they were doing anything that penguin in
a Parker has always planned to do the
Stargate franchise once they were
complete with the God of War series for
Amazon that they needed to get those
scripts done and agreed so filming could
start on that and while they were busy
they couldn't start Stargate now that
idea was always to have those scripts
for the God of War series done by now so
that these potential strike would not
affect the filming schedule they then
could finish negotiations and
conversations with Amazon about Stargate
and announce it in mid-june I'm being
told by my sources in around Amazon and
MGM that those plans are still very much
a go and that actually the right to
strike will not make any difference at
all to their plans for the Stargate
franchise the idea will be still for a
movie to begin filming by the end of
this year and potentially to be in our
Cinemas by the end of 2024 or early
2025. there has been however some rumors
about the search for a new director now
one of the people I speak to is actually
works at rather a large Hollywood talent
agency they said that one of the clients
of that agency a director I can't say
who but trust me you would know the name
was approached and was asked that if he
would be interested in having a
conversation about this potential Star
Game movie now this director said that
due to scheduling he couldn't say yes or
no straight away but that they were
interested while they were looking at
their schedule to see whether it was a
possibility the offer of a discussion
was withdrawn the most likely reason for
this withdrawal was that they made the
same offer to two or three directors
one of them said yes
and that they began negotiating in good
faith with that person now we don't know
who that is just yet but it's further
evidence that they are in fact looking
for a director and just maybe they found
them
so this could be one more big step
towards the Stargate franchise now let's
go over to the studio and let's have a
chat about what we think all of this
means
[Music]
I'm sorry about saying going back to the
studio just abuses me it tickled me you
said that and I was like I'm just gonna
stare into the camera with like my mud
for a minute
[Music]
um but I've taken over the middle
I got to play
every little old man sandwich
oh
I'm middle-aged oh yeah
you're lucky you guys are lucky this is
a monetized channel or I'd say all so
much stuff
oh yes thank you guess we've we don't we
have stormy flat
um yeah see you next Tuesday and destroy
the channel every chance he gets
um MLP story comes back soon we I loved
having him on I had a midweek Channel
last week it was brilliant I'm going to
start we'll start doing some midweek
lives so it's just we can get stormy
back anyway he's fun to watch too I
always enjoyed watching him when I was
just watching this so yeah he's a clever
guy as well the stuff and nobody do it
like Danny Gandolf does it
this is the truth
um just in the comments you mentioned
there Harris about going to San Diego
Comic-Con we are over here at Sidetrack
might have a beginnings
an early set of a plan to actually
Wander over to America next year and go
to San Diego Comic Con and meet young
Harris meet young stormy meet young
parents maybe and do some videos and
guys if we get to do that it'll be
because the new amazing subscribers that
come week after week to watch us stupid
ranting videos
um because we wouldn't be able to do it
else and they were all there I I have to
do and Matt has to do is get the wives
to agree but
or bring them with tell them they're
coming to America for a week they're
just not they're not going to the parks
they want to tell them to go have a
girls like weekend while you're actually
doing all the nerdy stuff at Comic-Con
yeah I've got a whole week of nerdy
stuff planned I want to go to like the
rocks in the the Star Trek Crocs and I
want to go to all these other places so
yeah I got a week at she's going to be
like oh can we go shopping and I'll be
like I'm I'm gonna go over there where
they filmed that episode of Star Trek
next Generation once the the Japanese
garden is three minutes behind my house
in the park behind us it's uh the place
where they film it's where the uh uh
Starfleet Academy is it's like the whole
building and all that
as well
but anyway we at least a big place
my problem they're barely opening the
life they are my problem would be
convincing them to go
yeah I'm saying no I don't want the wife
to go I'm not asking him
she would be she would totally be down
for that trip it'd be a question of you
know how hell are we going to pay for
stuff when we are there
no no I'm gonna I'm just gonna like fish
from the Pacific Ocean and stuff to pay
for it you better say California likes
to beg that question every day I ask
myself that
I'm texting barbecue baby damn right and
yeah y'all are gonna come out here and
I'm gonna feed y'all just we're gonna
teach you what a real barbecue is don't
worry don't worry so anyway as Mike says
back to the studio Stargate news very
very briefly a direct have been
approached it possibly we don't know
that's certain but and the director was
approached that I do know about
um after the video ends I'll tell you
who it was you'll love it
um and then
um obviously while they were having a
chat about well basically the idea was
the this director was very interested
but they've said [__] scheduling I've
got stuff on the go already so how could
we work this and while they were trying
to figure out sort of the calendar
um
MGM withdrew the offer and the offer
wasn't too direct it wasn't a here's a
job offer it was a would you like to
have a conversation about maybe doing
this offer and at some point that thing
goes wrong so it looks like there may be
talking to somebody else
first of all I know that's
they are best but what do you think
about that from this time because for me
I think that's a positive step in the
right direction
if the writer strikes happening right
now and there's no further from from
that standpoint it would be nice to get
someone in there as a director and
really focus on another pivotal aspect
of the the film the show Running of the
series whatever it may be uh and and
really get your puzzle pieces together
while we're waiting for the writing to
continue
yeah well not to mention the Director's
Guild is up next so yeah yeah
you know if you needed if you need to
lock down a director you got about a
month or two I can't remember when the
dga's negotiations or I can't remember
what their cutoff date it's June or July
I think it's June 1st something like
that yeah so in about a month we might
have no directors as well so yeah
Hollywood if you need a good director
get your poop in gear and start writing
checks you're gonna have one in a month
yeah mind something is that they're not
as worried about the Apparently for
months now that people have known the
right strike is going to happen but
there seems to be a little bit more
confidence in the directors they're not
asking for as much
reasonably good I think actually the
negotiations opens June 1st so they're
not even going to start talk until June
1st and then they've got a little while
but um but apparently that's reasonably
so sorry Ace Lisa's Kim Smith do you
think Kevin Smith's going to be the
director I love Kevin Smith Kevin Smith
is amazing I want Kevin Smith 20 years
ago maybe but then all anybody would
ever do is talk to each other and they
wouldn't do anything else and I love a
great guest director on an episode of
Stargate or something but not
yeah yeah oh yeah it'd be brilliant just
come in for like a first silly joke you
know you know one of the comedies yeah
like the one I can never remember the
name of it my favorite one of that type
is uh one O'Neal and teal were stuck in
that Loop and just started messing
around in the base yeah
exactly that'd be amazing but but no not
as a um not as a shower movie yeah
um but but yeah no but I can I can see
where you're coming from with that
um no no no they say the person they
know they've semi-approached
big sci-fi actor big sci-fi oh I said
too much of them
there's a lot of big sci-fi actors out
there it's okay but anyway
um it was but he was like so he said oh
maybe I think that's positive story
um do you think I say I'm saying that
they're actually the two or three people
I've spoken to now that are quite close
to it who said the the writer strike
isn't going to affect anything with
Stargate they knew this was going to
happen
they're not worried it was all part of
the plan okay oh uh generalization
um yeah all the guilds are up this year
it goes right it goes writers then
directors then what producers no yeah
there's not gonna be any problem with
producers though no and directors are
half the time our producers as well
which is probably why they're gonna be
okay with most things but when it comes
to actors and maybe crew like the ayatsi
strike a couple years ago all like the
crew members uh for production that
might
they might strike it's gonna be all the
little fish it feels like more so than
the the executives you know yeah the
writers that were kind of stuffing away
is the because they can
they I don't I honestly don't think we
talked about this last week I honestly
don't think the producers mind the
writers going on strike a bit they can
squeeze the deal a bit more and they can
hopefully negotiate but they can carry
on film and stuff where the righteous go
strike at least for a bit
Hollywood stops
yeah well like like even with the writer
strike going on right now I believe both
Warner Brothers and uh uh Disney are the
two that were like okay we're
immediately doing this they sent letters
out that said hey you might not be
writing but you still have if you're on
payroll like you still want to be and
your payroll is going to keep getting
larger according to the writer strike
and all that you're gonna have to work
outside of your writing duties because
it's part of their contract that they
have things to do outside of writing
Duty so they're still at the studio
working
when they're not picket fence line you
know it's it's kind of interesting on a
lot of levels I don't know entire what
to think about it from either side
there's good points on both sides I
think
yeah I spoke to a writer that um that I
that I do know that yes has worked on a
couple of franchises we might be
discussing today so
um but anyway he says to me because most
writers they're still writing
stuff and this is what we love to do
because they get they'll then get when
there's right strikes doing they'll get
paid for stuff they give in and they say
because you'll be amazed how many
writers all of a sudden have like 30
scripts that they've just magically
appeared and I'll go look at all this
work I've done
um in the last week since the strike
ended honest and so it's a lot writers
are still working they just can't
give it in yeah something so it's like
doing your homework but not giving it
the teacher yeah but it allows them to
have like a little bit of a repertoire
just to toss out when they're ready
which is kind of nice
um it lasted 90 days Gary it lasted
about three months
so yeah it felt like a year okay I don't
know I was too young
yeah I think Bob's accurate on that one
yeah
yeah 100 days ish wasn't it yeah
um
but I would highlight Bob's
I'm not highlighting one is to spend
over
is there another one he said because no
no that's the one I'm talking about
yeah but 100 days-ish
so anyway
um is there anything she went through in
there I think there's some good positive
things but I the one thing I would say
is that I've spoken to a few people
there's loads of rumors knocking around
about actors I'm gonna do a video on
that next week a couple of them you'd be
quite excited by
um but the one guy I did speak to says
look there's loads of rumors going
around because loads of people are
trying to get this start everyone
expects Stargate to get announced it's
going to be the next big franchise that
nobody's attached to already sort of
thing so everyone just you know agents
and everything are trying to get their
guy
their guy in this now so there's loads
of rumors going around here so we've got
to be really careful what we what we
listen to what we don't I I put this
down to like football rooms as you guys
know I'm a big man united fan I love my
football sometimes an agent will go oh
we've got this player and he's he's man
united are interested and man united are
not bloody interested but they're trying
to get a contract for something else so
they're trying to get him on a job
somewhere so we're going to get loads
and loads and loads of rumors knocking
around because people are trying to push
that guy forward but actual real stuff
coming from MGM
it's gone very quiet
and this is an MGM of being okay and and
you know like this director's thing
um I have to be really careful what I
say about that because I was told very
clearly
um that they were verbally aggressively
said that this must not get leaked and
that that's what I'm saying there was
very you know when they said um
basically that's approaching this
director we would love to talk to him
and obviously the agents are going what
do you want to talk to him about and
apparently took three or four attempts
to get anything out of them at all they
did not want to tell them what it was
about they just they just kept saying I
just want to talk to him about him and
they said no and look I'm his agent I I
want to know what you want to talk to
him
and eventually they said yes it's about
the potentially
um a project at MGM and then eventually
they said yes okay it's a Sci-Fi project
at MGM
okay fine it's Stargate surprised
but so we're gonna we'll I think the
leaks will we've had loads and loads of
leaks that we've really been lucky
enough to get through this channel
I don't think we've been getting so many
in the next couple of months but we'll
see
um or we'll get stuff that's but I'm
being really really careful anyway
at least for me it seems like when they
clamp down like that that's a good sign
yeah doing things they don't want people
to know about which means they're doing
things that well hopefully we're going
to like but it means they're doing
things like doing yeah we always tell
this 18 months ago when I first started
this channel I was told that there would
be a route to this there's certain
things you watch for the first thing was
started seeing articles in magazines on
you know Screen Rants and all this sort
of thing about all this just randomly
talking about Stargate for no reason and
it'll be like oh remember that Stargate
show and they did that would start and
then we'd start getting articles that
were more focused
um for the anniversary came and went we
had a lot of stuff on that and we had
the article on Deadline about a month
ago now
and then he said just before an
announcement everything would go dead
quiet and that seems to be where we're
heading into at the moment it's the dead
quiet face so it's panned out just as he
told me it would basically so yeah okay
so unless there's anything else
fantasy CEO
yeah
cool right so yeah game we've invented
we are taking a streaming service each
eye Amazon Prime Larry
they were burping thank you
you want to play a game
um okay baby I want to play a game
um Aaron You Are I Am Netflix you are
playing as Netflix today and Harris you
are playing as the evil
I'm revving the blue Disney plus
so in this game we are going you have
obviously throwing honorable mentions
where if you like but you have to pick
one TV show that is currently running
that you want to cancel
you have to I'm sorry renew first so one
TV show that is currently running that
you want to renew so you want more of it
damn it you are going to cancel a
television series it is currently
running you are going to steal a
television show from another Network
where you have to say why you think it
deserves to be on yours well you'll
treat it better and you can bring back
one big project from the past
um Lord of the Rings rings of power I
wonder how he means
um we watched it yesterday
you did indeed so I I will start if
that's okay gentlemen yeah and I will
throw in my renew
first
obviously I don't have as much original
material as you guys to choose from
Prime tends to buy lots of things from
other places but there are two shows
that really at the moment that Amazon
Prime are running that I really really
adore and I really want more of
the first season of Jack Reacher or just
Reacher sorry
um I thought was just a Triumph from
beginning to end every episode was
focused it was absolutely on the ball
the adaptation from one of the books I
just thought was absolutely spot on but
that's not what I've picked because it's
actually getting the second season I'm
doing it's obviously certainly going to
be getting the third season after that
Citadel is a new TV series that's just
been released created by the Russo
Brothers it stars um Richard Madden
Stanley Tucci and Priyanka Jonas I've
only seen the first couple of episodes
it's very high concept it's almost
sci-fi in the way it's been made
um but it's about spies and it's about
like lots of intrigue
I really really would love this show to
get a second season I hope they do it
very quickly
but I don't think they will get a second
season or maybe they'll get a second
season but that'll be it
for two reasons
this show must cost a bloody Fortune to
make I mean this this must be really
really expensive it's gonna get a lot of
use for to be loved but also I suspect
Richard Madden is going to be the next
James Bond
and in that case
The Citadel will not go to second season
but if I was in charge and for day I am
The Citadel would be renewed immediately
for a second season because it's bloody
brilliant very very good and as I say
almost almost
sci-fi in nature so again we allow it
so Netflix
Aaron sir which show would you like to
renew
I would like them to continue the last
Kingdom foreign
um I know I I think they basically just
finished it off with a movie
uh like seven Kings must die or
something like that however
um that technically is just the end of
the story of Wessex finally just barely
starting to bring England together they
could easily continue that
and just call it like you know
the last Kingdom England Rises or
something like that because you know how
much history you've got on that island
and they're only they're not even in the
they haven't even hit the first
Millennium yet in that show it's still
the the years are still three digits
they got a lot they could cover and I
think they could do really well with it
so I would keep the last Kingdom going
yeah history's where it comes from here
actually all of your history it comes
from here
I got all this back here
there's a joke over here that um when
they were planning to build Euro Disney
that they um realized about halfway
through that they're gonna have to build
the castle load bigger because we've got
them here it's like so we kind of got
this fiberglass castle and go this is
crap
I mean it's around the corner from my
house is better than this so they built
it bigger bigger than they were planning
if it's true I love that story but uh it
makes sense you wouldn't think of it
so that's the show I would continue on
with Netflix is going to get a new
series of the last Kingdom fantastic you
know what I've never watched it oh dude
it's good so should I okay yeah I'll
give it a go I will go I have never seen
it either but I've literally had two
people tell me this week to watch it one
was like that movie was so good and was
freaking out about the movie and I was
like huh you got five seasons to show
before the movie I mean
that's not bad is it yeah
I don't know it's quite violent or
whatever isn't it it's probably like
taco salad
it's it you wouldn't want your
seven-year-old watching it I'll tell you
that it's it's graphic in multiple ways
so so I've got like a four-year-old can
I no
two-digit aged child should not watch
that show I didn't know that yeah and
the lady I mentioned
um Priyanka and president Ron Jonas is
married to a Jonas brother I wondered
where she comes from I just like yeah
her name is Priyanka Chopra but it's
Priyanka Chopra Jonas now uh I just
stopped the chopper because I didn't
know Jonah's sister so which is probably
his sister
um right so cool so Disney plus then sir
good luck with this
um what show do you think on Disney plus
the most loved of all of the streaming
services of course you made my job so
easy thank you I just knew you'd like it
so what show currently running would you
like to renew and technically it's a
mini series
but we've all thought they were going to
renew it for season two and they haven't
yet
as much as the first one is
iffy at times there there was definite
greatness within the show nonetheless I
would renew book of Boba Fett for season
two
okay sell that to us
um the book above episodes
literally everything's still there to be
awesome and great and now we have even
more ingredients for it to be awesome
and great it's just I wish those
ingredients hadn't slow baked as much as
they had they were slow cooking
yeah
so okay you're gonna have to sell this
one to a smoke because
um we obviously have some issues with
the show well it fits perfectly into
Ahsoka and Mando and the whole Mando
verse going on so that's that's not too
difficult it's already a corner of that
it's it's it being a Cornerstone it
needs to amp itself up up a little bit
because that's not the strongest
Cornerstone to be sitting on you know
they've got a Rancor they've got
mandalorians they've got Phoenix Shand
kill off the Vespa Squad but do it in a
really cool fashion or something over
the season I don't know or make them
cool one or the other
there's options but it can be doable and
it interweaves within Ahsoka you can
really put a lot of that Rangers in the
new Republic stuff and book a Boba Fett
if you want to but it allows for Star
Wars to be live action gritty dark
underworld and it but we just have to
see it instead of being Papa Boba Fett
we need gangster criminal Godfather Boba
Fett and if we get back to that life's
good baby Life's good can I suggest an
alternative
is you know as an outsider I I own my
own I own my own massive um streaming
service now so you know it's like
professionals talking to each other
something
the book of fenik sand instead
well that's that's would be a whole
different thing we're talking about
renewing a certain thing that's already
been done I'm sticking within the
stipulations yeah but the best bits of
the book of Bob effect were the bits
when he wasn't in it so I would just say
we'll call it the book of Boba Fett
but you don't have him in it
or just have them in the background
um
we we uh we renew book of boba fed but
the the next chapter we call it the
chapter of Shand or the chapter of
Finnick or something like that okay we
just focus on that
on the whole I thought it was all right
um
so yeah okay we're getting more Boba
Fett
as long as we write it correctly that's
cool yeah pretty much what it comes down
to
guys go and get into the comments now
and for the next couple of minutes while
we start doing the next bit
which of the three shows that we are
going to renew would you actually renew
and um Kerry who is watching at the
moment who is going to judge today can
decide so and she doesn't know that I've
not told her but Kerry I'm putting you
on the spot you need the chat Master now
exactly so which of the shows that we're
going to do are we actually going to
renew and I'm going to play a quick
trailer and then we're going to go into
which show we're going to cancel
nine chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to
news stories that we break check out
some of the news articles that we have
already at nineshavrons.com
I was just cracking up the second that
happened because you were like what show
we want to cancel nine chevrons.com
Jay closes his own website exactly and
before we even start so Kerry you need I
need an answer from you Kerry
Citadel last Kingdom or book of Boba
Fett which show we actually keep it so
cancel
I have very easy job as far as I'm
concerned and I a little bit of a theme
that I'm having another spy TV series
that I'm going to cancel because I
watched two seasons of this crap
it's boring
um it never very rarely goes anywhere I
was really really looking forward to it
when it came out because I loved the
movies and I've Loved most of the books
so and I actually really like the actor
that plays the lead character
it's and it's not that it's badly done
it's boring
the Jack Ryan TV series
just get rid of it
it's we're getting the third season is
going to be out soon they've already
Greenly to fourth season well until
today when I took over and I immediately
canceled it
it's it's just it's boring and for me
that's like the worst crime of any show
that's the credentiality one huh yes so
John kasinski you are you better be
getting the part on um Fantastic Four
you're not but you better be getting it
because you're you're out of job now
mate because I'm sacking
no there will be no season four of Jack
Ryan if I have
anything to do with it which for today I
do so and that's that's mostly what it
comes down to it's just crap
um Kerry wasn't listening look at that
Jay what are the options you've always
said
somebody wasn't listening
sit down here we go book a Boba Fett
yeah no I I don't know if you're uh
you're kind of cheating a little bit
there Jay because I think Mojo just just
commented I'm pretty sure Jack Ryan is
gonna be its final season season already
so you're canceling something that's
it's already happening
the next season is season three say
season four was announced uh
okay not necessarily oh
so um at the moment they say it was
there was rumors it was going to be
canceled after season three and then
they announced season four
so
now yeah yeah I win I know
it's good show anyway
what Carrie help me out here yeah but
even even if there were rumors or even
if they're saying about it being
canceled it's definitely getting
canceled so we're not arguing about it
anymore it's going I hate it the only
other thing is I was thinking about the
cartoon of the boys not like that either
so um
I don't like it so I tried to watch it I
didn't like it so that's that's that
might just go as well just because I'm
feeling mean now so all right
so right so how about Netflix what are
we canceling oh this one like you I
found this one quite easy
Witcher is done I'm not even letting
Liam Hemsworth on my show as soon as
soon as the last episode of season three
is gone with Cavill so is that show just
done
I mean
Kettle left what more do I need to say
the show's done
yeah yep season four no chance
um Jack Ryan by the way I'm canceling
season four so even if that show has
been done I'm going to start happening
so there we go I've got around the rules
myself sorry I've just decided we're not
we're not making season four so even if
I'm wrong about it being canceled anyway
so yeah which in season four um mate I'm
with you on that I think that's strong
I cannot see how that series is gonna
work I mean as soon as I went back over
the list that you put up that was like
cancel oh Witcher don't move on to the
next one
like straight up I didn't even think
about it like cancel I got Netflix up
Witcher yeah and the blood sees serious
to me um I forgot what it's called I did
watch it Michelle yo oh the the origin
whatever
um to be honest as soon as I watched
that and like this franchise is dead
this is dead Henry Cavill is gonna put
the last nail in it and
13 audience rating like and and and
I don't know what the Rotten Tomatoes is
but I know it's not any prettier
I'm wondering who those 13 of people
that are watching that crap enjoying it
I think that's just like yeah
what's wrong with the sad it's awful we
don't have time for that dude no we
don't
and even the things
next week on Sidetrack what's wrong with
you people
Society Get It Together
but man I oh dude that is wrong that's a
strong Shout
Harris Can you
go see
well I don't know about that I'm I'm
following suit and I'm gonna let the
next season air and then it's done uh
because I and we talked about a little
yesterday I just wasn't a fan of it uh
I'm canceling Loki after season two I I
think it's it's BS sci-fi I don't think
it's real sci-fi I don't think it tries
to be and it it doesn't even take
Concepts and does them right it had a
good first episode a decent seventh
episode and a good eighth episode
and the only reason eighth episode was
good was
because Jonathan Majors was King and was
excellent in that moment but now that
was that on the fritz there's no reason
to keep this show around recast King and
do something entirely different and uh
yeah put Loki back in the movies don't
relegate Tom Hiddleston to the freaking
TV shows I I love TV I'm a big TV guy
but Tom Hiddleston needs to be on the
big screen that's a little screen that's
it show is so cheap to make I mean it's
only it's it's it's so cost effective
you may as well almost just make it
really
um because that's not bad
it's it's in the top 10 most expensive
TV shows I was about to say it's
straight CG it's expensive as I'll get
out like expensive well I think it's
like fourth or something in the top ten
list something like that and and put and
just on that same list like put Loki
next to rings of power I would watch
rings of power over that any day of the
week just because of the way obviously
that's just another expensive show but
neither one or like
oh yeah that's Game of Thrones level or
that's that's uh the expanse level or
anything like that it's the last Kingdom
level because I know people went to the
last Kingdom After Game of Thrones uh
and stuff like that you know but
neither one of those hit that Mark and
they're just expensive for the sake of
being expensive that's it just quickly
go through this rings of power is
obviously number one strange things is
obviously number two uh
MCU 25 MC Marvel series it just says
Marvel series what how's the dragon be
up there yet or no yeah I think that
must be Loki it just says Marvel series
for some reason yeah
um but but yeah I think that's Loki so
it's the third most expensive show ever
made
uh the Pacific
House of the dragon's fifth Game of
Thrones six the Mandalorian the seventh
C was eighth Morning Show but that's
just paying for Jennifer Aniston and
Reese Witherspoon and then ER comes in
at 10th really ER was expensive to me 13
million dollars an episode
towards the end
um but yeah
I'm with you on that right answer's tied
oh no I'm overruling you Kerry I'm sorry
The Witcher has to die
well no you you know you saw what she
said you put Carrie in charge and you
read two chats after that real quick
which is wrong
Barry we love you very very much and we
look forward to having you on the show
at one point but as it's been pushed
back a month now
um but as as the supreme leader of
Sidetrack I have to step in
I'm saying I'm sorry Aaron was bang on
it has to die it has to die
um I mean it has to die quickly so
um
I support you in your decision
um Harris don't get me wrong
no actually do get me wrong I quite like
Loki so
um
well that's another discussion
[Laughter]
um we love Kerry very much but right so
Steel
we could steal it right the next one
though carry out okay you can have the
next one I promise I will not over real
quick I've already won this round y'all
go ahead
I'm stealing Star Trek
yeah I've always
well I'm actually going to
um okay Kerry fine fine I'm a little bit
scared of you so that's fine we will
kill Loki and The Witcher there you go
we'll kill them both uh Hey one big
swing we'll call zazlov for an assist
you know
I love the heads off both swing though
yes you got to go ax with zazlov
so Star Trek right parameter in massive
financial problems I mean music like I
mean like moose
so many financial problems but I'm
pretty sure I now own Paramount and I
didn't I did it by accident
um I bought a subscription they said can
I have the company and I just went oh
okay oh [__] I know my own primary
um that's much better
um so
um I am going to steal Star Trek
um I don't want the Star Trek though
that they're planning because I don't
want Star Trek Academy 90210 I don't
want it
um I'll have strange new worlds and I'll
have Legacy because I'm that's that's a
new show I'm but I'm bending the rules
here because I want it and um and um and
I want um lower decks so I am stealing
Star Trek the main reason Paramount
cannot afford to do it justice and over
here at Amazon I can so my reason for
stealing it is it's awesome but it needs
Investments and
Paramount content so
Star Trek and it's not completely
logical because I've already half stolen
it anyway because
um Paramount have been sorry we've
co-funded the last three seasons of
Picard so
we win
so I'm having Star Trek thank you very
much
Netflix oh by the way because I'm the
judge of this is um I'm having Star Trek
I've already put a tick next to it so
um you can you can just speak now for
the next couple of minutes I'm not
listening but anyway Aaron what are you
stealing sir well um I'm actually going
to free you up some money and I'm gonna
bring rings of power on over to Netflix
Oh interesting you want to destroy
Netflix are you trying to no no no no no
no no no no no no no if I'm running
rings of power I'm going to do it better
okay
but that's the question are you running
rings of Power are you just executing it
and putting it over is it still the same
people
no it's going to be people I hire okay
like my my first phone call is going to
be to Peter Jackson like Brett
I know Amazon's a bunch of Pricks
but come on I want to do it right and in
order for me to do it right I need you
so
come on down man
help PJ
come on and then from there we'll move
on and with like good script writers
eliminate some of the fluff which will
help me afford good stuff so yeah it's
just just a basic uh a behind the scenes
buy it overall overhaul up behind the
scenes and then put it out better done
and also then you'd have the opportunity
potentially
to do a deal with is it Warner Brothers
Warner Brothers isn't it
yes do something with Warner Brothers
and tie rings of power into the new
movies they're playing
which would be nice uh Warner Brothers
and Amazon potentially could do that as
well they've got a reasonably good
working relationship but
that's what I do
yeah yeah I take rings apart and just
redo the behind the scenes people
like if the actor I mean unless they
were just actual because I haven't
watched it yet no I'm not gonna I'll be
honest about that but like unless they
have actual Bad actors all the actors
are doing is dealing with the writing
they're given anyway so yeah the actors
are all fine honestly
so just brought sword all the producers
and the things we're just Witcher yep
exactly I'll bring Peter Jackson I'll
bring Peter Jackson in I'll give him an
orc costume or a urukai costume and let
them go to town that's all just dealing
around the world your needs society
would be right then the world would be
righted yep completely I gotta say
strong again
strong I'm saving Star Trek but you're
saving rings of power you're you're
saving Tolkien I can feel stormy at the
moment going do that
from all the way
um it's strong strong so Harris what are
you gonna steal and why
let's let's see if I can uh uh just
blow blow your socks off real quick
because this is this is the best thing
that Disney money could ever be
allocated to hey you know what
Netflix screwed this up so monumentally
by making such an amazing show
and doing absolutely nothing with it
canceling it while it was winning Emmys
for them
I'm stealing The Dark Crystal age of
resistance and putting it on Netflix and
letting lucasfilm and Jim Henson work
their magic just like they should have
been doing from the beginning and we're
going to get the best damn show ever
because that was a perfect season of
television and I don't know what any
Netflix executive was ever thinking
canceling it and we're we're going ham
baby that's all I'm saying do you know
this is after the genius idea as well
all those people on Willow have just
been sacked
them to do it
but but we're we're hiring The Dark
Crystal team that we had before because
we'll let lucasfilman Henson company
work together again but well they're
gonna be some stipulations I gotta say
The Dark Crystal done better
would be good
I just I'm still pissed at Netflix for
that one
you guys have been okay Carrie we're
gonna need an answer me darling but I
think I'm out
sorry Star Trek yeah let's just cancel
starter
um
but um I I think I'll continue to spend
money on a parametrical continuous
memory of this crap
Darth Disney and Dark Crystal is back at
it
I I think though that honestly guys you
both of you guys have had
really really strong thoughts on that I
think more people would be made Happy by
rings of power but I would love to see
doctor still done right it was just done
so well and I just I'm still pissed at
them canceling it it's just come on
idiots
right so we have another quick thing to
run and then we're going into our last
one
the show that was canceled
that you want to bring back that you
want to resurrect
I um can I just I I remember at MGM now
can I say Stargate now or should I
actually come up with something properly
now I'll come up with something properly
um but we'll be back in one second
Sidetrack also has some amazing merch
get yours today and show your support at
SCI dashtrack.com
do
right so
um Matt did bother doing those videos
and I actually thought you know what I
should probably use them
and it's been ages making them he's not
here little did he know in the process
of you using them you canceled nine
Chevrons it's just I know I know I did
that by mistake but never mind and I've
just spent an hour writing a story for
it so you revive is now being used on
nine Chevrons instead of Stargate or
what or what it's gonna have to be
um so for me
as the new owner of Amazon Jeff at my
seat
um
I I only had one choice didn't I and now
I'm going to use my telepathic abilities
and I'm I'm not going to say what it is
just everybody in the comments what do
you think Amazon show I am going to
bring back that's been canceled recently
Aaron any ideas
oh crap uh expense
what a stupid idea Harris any ideas
uh the Farscape
no because that's not I'm missing you
idiot I just saw it in the comments
of course it's the expanse you can do
this
um Amazon still own the expanse they
still have the um coin the distribution
rights
um it is already owned by a different
company called who actually own the IP
but Amazon for the next 12 months or so
own the distribution I think we could
bring this back if we wanted to and now
I'm in charge we're getting so it will
not be a an immediate series we will not
go into book seven instead we're going
to do some bridging series
um based on different I want to explore
other parts of the Galaxy and then we're
going to go into book Seven in a couple
of Seasons
um it's all going to be very exciting
and yeah the expanse is back baby
because I'm in charge
it's a no-brainer I did think about like
the Man in the Iron castle and a couple
of other shows that have been canceled
over the years with um Amazon but to be
honest
the expanse is the one that needs to
come back and if I don't do it somebody
else will
It's gotta be the expense
Aaron how about yourself sir who do you
want to bring back well
um I think it's a thunder stealer over
here
my revive was Dark Crystal age of
resistance
I was gonna bring that back until
this guy stole it it technically still
works yeah but yeah no I would totally I
would totally bring Dark Crystal age
resistance back
I mean
it had a 89 critic score on Rotten
Tomatoes a 94 audience score
why in the hell are you canceling a
season with the show with those numbers
not to mention
the fact that like you got our
generation going Dark Crystal
and then you know if those of us who
have kids or whatever grandkids well we
can lock them in for them too I mean
come on bro what is wrong with you so
yeah
there's all there's all puppets though
just it's like so 1990. yes you can
generate some stuff man it's like none
of that man it was so much better
because it wasn't like honestly if I Was
a Movie Maker I would still use as much
practical effects as I could on the ucgi
where I absolutely had to
is the problem yeah sometimes
but yeah this story before but you know
that
um that preacher series set them Seth uh
the Seth Rogen the AMC one Rogan did AMC
yeah first season brilliant second
season third season
um but the first the opening sequencer
is this like rocket it's like it's
supposed to look like 1950s supposed to
look like it's on a wire with like
fireworks at the back
and Seth wanted to do an actual like he
wanted to do that with like do it real
you know do it with actual proper
um things they said it was going to cost
50 000 to do and it was much much
cheaper to do with CGI so they went well
we'll do a CJ then so it just that's the
thing practical effects are generally
always better but CGI is much much
cheaper
um which is weird it shouldn't be but it
is but then also you think about
um the John Wick series of movies first
John Wick series movie no CGI
the last one
much CGI which yeah
yeah I haven't seen that yet the first
one's a brilliant movie the fourth one
is not so much
it's not it's not it's not nothing like
as good as the first one I've seen the
first
because a lot of people say it's their
favorite I'm not it's probably
a the second one I might not like as
much as this one but it's one of those
two I I love them all but it's two or
four that's like typed with replacement
it's better than the third one the
fourth one is better than the third one
really I love the third one I think the
third one is X or I think is much better
than the second one but nothing touches
the first the first one was just
it's like the first taken or something
like that it was such a surprise hit as
well it was just
simplistically brilliant
um they've over complicated over
complicated and got to a point in the
fourth one where and don't get me wrong
I love putting bits of the fourth one
I'll quite happy to watch it again but
the whole Arc to Triumph fit I'm just
like this is [__] stupid what the
hell is going on here and the friendship
can't drive that well this is ridiculous
um now because no one stop I know the
French are rude but no one's stopping to
ask what's going on nobody no one yeah
it's like let's just
and then at one point he has to walk up
a flight of stairs and it takes four
winks
I was old by the time I went to the
toilet twice I know I'm old I have to go
to the toilet I went to the toilet twice
and he was still falling down the bloody
stairs by the time I got back it was no
it was stupid well not to mention he had
to fall back down the stairs and walk
back up like twice yeah I can walk with
my broken knees I could walk upstairs
quicker than he could
um
yeah and I I love Keanu Reeves he's
[__] nice but no okay now compared to
the first one it's just
yeah this was around about CGI and it
just became a massive rant about this
movie is the CGI in it I I think if
you're doing a fight movie like that if
you can't do it for real don't do it
just don't do it I I have the same
argument for fast The Fast and the
Furious films the first one no cgis a
much better movie in lots of ways than
all the others that came after just if
you can't do it in real life don't do it
don't use a bloody CJ it looks like a it
looks like I'm playing under my mat at
home with my little toy cars
around corners and [__] no that's stupid
anyway sorry
um what did you say Aaron uh I'm
bringing back Dark Crystal a group of
resistance yes okay cool bring it back
Dark Crystal fantastic as it never
should have been gone
Disney what are you bringing back
all right well this is where Disney plus
does not help out because it is a newer
streaming service and it also does not
have many originals and most of the
originals are not things that General
audiences are typically into I don't
think I'm Reviving The Mighty Ducks or
anything like that anytime soon as much
as I do like the original movie the T
what do you watch the show
Emilio always but I don't even know they
had another season uh so yeah Disney
plus doesn't have too many options on
this one so once again all right
the what you know they own Fox though
right
yeah but they haven't done like if if I
went back because I'm doing this just
off of Disney plus originals and I guess
I could have done Hulu but we're doing
Disney not not Hulu so I'm just doing
that I'm not doing like Disney if I was
just doing Disney TV shows
I would have had a whole different
conversation because I then I'd be
telling like some Lilo and Stitch or
something because that's just that makes
money you've stepped within the spirit
of the rules exactly
National Treasure
that was not a good show at all
it'll be telling us next that
um
show ever made
was what's the best show folks I've ever
made Futurama Always Forever but
rational treasure was awful that first
season the worst ever
I did watch the first few episodes
mainly because I'm in love with Michael
Douglas's wife yeah Catherine Zeta Jones
every time she was on that screen I was
just like why isn't the show about her
and and all the main like I I don't like
talking bad on actors like okay it might
have just been been a bad day of work
but damn that was a bad series at work
because all four of those actors the
young actors are not
actors that they should have just been
on like a reality TV show that was they
there was no emotion ever coming from
any of them I don't think any of them
have ever taken acting classes and I
mean I like I said I don't I I don't
want to poo poo on a bunch of actors but
that show makes me want to poop on a
bunch of actors because
but in the spirit of book of Boba Fett
had some some light in the dark and and
if you draw upon the light you could
keep moving on with it
uh uh yeah you could you could just
bring back well you can't bring back
Catherine Zeta Jones but you could you
could do some stuff along the lines of
that just bring back real National
Treasure people that's it but it's I'm
I'm with Kerry I just just ask just
quickly obviously owning
Disney plus and Disney now shows shows
that from the fox era Etc right so you
could have said something like The
X-Files
yes no I would have had to think on it a
lot more differently uh
Daredevil you could have brought back
Jessica Jones or The Punisher but you're
bringing back
National Treasure I was within a certain
set of stipulations you have it allowed
to think out of the box a little bit
though Harris well okay well then I'm
bringing back Lilo and Stitch so they
don't do the live action animation or
live action stuff I just okay
my childhood would be safe so it's a
much better answer
anyway because Kerry has spoken she may
Carrie about 20 minutes ago got bored of
listening to you and just wrote
she's like status National Treasure
balls
Daredevil is already coming back as I
said we're getting Daredevil back next
year so you could have brought back
Jessica Jones
well who's to say they're not going to
be there already
yeah they're already talking Punisher
there
yeah oh he's confirmed yeah
I just wouldn't be surprised if they did
pass like a Jessica Jones in there maybe
a little they were trying to get her
they still haven't officially not gotten
her yet
they they wanted her from what I
understand
uh Bernthal is getting a lot of the
punishers getting a lot of the screen
time they wanted for Jessica Jones in
the first place but what's her father's
had some scheduling issues so
they kind of Switched the uh co-star
they switched the uh other you know the
co-starness from her to him
for the show but
she's not completely out of it she just
won't be she could still be in it easily
she just won't be a significant part of
it the way they were originally going to
do it okay I'll tell you that works that
twins you bring back you have the series
Punisher folks you can't have too many
characters because the Defenders again
and then bring her into maybe towards
the end of the first season and then
make the second season more about
Jessica Jones and stuff because there's
still so many questions we had an answer
from Jessica Jones so I mean I'd love to
see that but all they can do is I'd want
to see the Daredevil from the Netflix
version of Daredevil I do not want to
see Daredevil from bloody She-Hulk
no I don't think I don't think you're
gonna well I don't think you'll see him
a lot
yeah I think it's going to be from what
I understand it's going to be a lot
closer to the Netflix
show than anything else from everything
I've read so far
good how many fingers can I cross I'm
gonna just I look like a Klingon or
something
they have said this is going to be more
in the violence more you know the the
darker version of this I think I think
it's supposed to be M.A I'm not 100 sure
on that like well
so let's have a quick recap and and I'll
try to remember who won each one so we
are going to be renewing
um
Citadel last Kingdom and The Book of
Boba Fett who won that one I can't
remember
uh you did yes so we're Revenue we're
canceling um Jack Ryan The Witcher and
locally but we're definitely getting rid
of The Witcher and Loki 100
um oh God which is just
so disappointed
um we're stealing I'm stealing Star Trek
you're stealing the ring of power Aaron
um and that that was genius to be honest
and Disney is stealing The Dark Crystal
which is to be honest where it belongs
it should be on Disney so I'm with you
on that 100
um bring him back we are bringing back
the expanse and hopefully Apple will
um we're bringing back the Dark Crystal
for Netflix but we're all in agreement
it should go to Disney and we're
bringing back Lilo and Stitch because
Harris is an idiot
we gotta have fun somewhere who we love
very very much but we're not bringing
back the [__] National Treasure
um so that show should never be made in
the first place but um anyway not
definitely not the way it was made
anyway yeah
like a proper movie but they made it
like a bloody CW TV series
I don't get why they used a bunch of
kids and put Justin bartha in one
episode just hi if you want to do a be
cash something do Justin bartha in the
show just yeah I don't get it
yeah uh Kerry won that one Kerry did win
that one thank you Carrie very very much
um
yeah
um guys that's it we're done oh what
about Warehouse 13. I don't know who
owns it but that was such a good show I
loved Warehouse 13. bring that back
that's gonna probably be Disney in it I
don't I don't know who ran I can't
remember which which channel it was like
assistant Network in it it wasn't on the
streaming service it was on a network
I know of it but I never saw it I never
watched it but I'm trying to thank you
I'll give it a go man it's really good
really good proper good Sci-Fi as well
um no thank you
um I've had the advantage though
I haven't had a disadvantage so I
thought because you love him Kerry but
um
Disney Disney's the disadvantage
thank you sir it was a Sci-Fi channel
you're right I remember that name no no
somebody's told me I remember that
um but yeah somebody should buy that and
get that back did the Sci-Fi channel
ever get bought out by like a larger
Studio or no no it's still running isn't
it
I did a video saying that that Arc the
The Arc TV show The you know where the
Chicago writers was actually quite good
I watched the first episode I'm quite
enjoyed it I tried to look past the crap
budget and I try to and I thought this
has got potential I've watched up to
about the fourth or fifth episode now
it hasn't
Matt was going off on it the other day
that was cracking me up oh yeah that was
hilarious yes he did didn't he might do
a video he was so angry about it might
do a video
so I probably recorded it right then uh
I hope you did but anyway guys so thank
you so so much for coming on and talking
to us again today it's I've been
absolutely brilliant I don't know yeah I
say we have a fun little game there
um call it Warehouse 14 for the reboot
why not that's how it works it was it
was one would implode and then you'd get
an extra but anyway it's basically a
magical Warehouse like all the aliens
and stuff where it's brilliant
um
um but anyway guys thank you again as I
say thank you so so much
um thank you for having me man
and Harris again because you're wearing
the merch as well mate love it so
available at sidesstrack.com
except doesn't got the Sidetrack logo
anymore
um so guys we will be back next week oh
no we will not be back next week sorry
because I've promised the wife a weekend
where I will not rush back so we will
not be live next week I will try to get
a video up on the Sunday just talking
whatever
um and um or I'll do some restore me I
don't know I'll figure something out
um we'll be back the following week and
we will be doing a Stargate special
video about what I don't know yet but
something happened
um but we're doing a special stagger so
it'll be Stargate live in two weeks from
today so say bye everybody
thank you peace
foreign
[Music]